[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire lé vaste métropole sont
elles l'avenir inéluctable de l'humanité
sont elles seulement le lieu où
s'élaborera la ville de demain pas si
sûr non seulement la pandémie de
qu'ovide invite les agglomérations à se
réinventer
mais leurs habitants sont incités à
quitter l'espace urbain trop dense trop
cher pour se réfugier à la campagne où
tout est plus calme plus écologique plus
durable alors faut-il quitté les villes
pour la campagne faute il a mené la
campagne à la ville où faut-il laisser
les villes comme elles sont parce que
c'est comme ça qu'on les aime pour un
débattre nous avons invité carlos moreno
vous êtes professeur des universités à
la sorbonne pionnier de la ville du
quart d'heure conseillers des grands
acteurs nationaux ou internationaux dont
la ville de paris anne hidalgo vous a
nommé son envoyé spécial villes
intelligentes êtes l'auteur de villes
urbaines et proximité de droite cité de
la ville monde à la ville du quart
d'heure les deux sont parus aux éditions
de l'observatoire les grandes villes
sont-elles encore l'avenir de l'humanité
pour vous oui bonjour merci pour
l'invitation où ils les grandes villes
restent quand même une référence
incontournable
un français à l'étranger et il s'avère
aujourd'hui plutôt dé gérer la
réconciliation avec les territoires qui
les entoure ce que nous appellons
l'alliance des territoires guillaume
fabuleux faburel vous êtes professeur à
l'université lumière lyon 2 vous êtes
l'auteur des métropoles barbares
démondialiser la ville d urbanisées la
terre et de pour en finir avec les
grandes villes manifeste pour une
société écologique post urbaine les deux
sont édités par le passager clandestin
les grandes villes encore l'avenir de
l'humanité pour vous bonsoir merci pour
l'invitation non je ne crois pas du tout
d'un point de vue écologique
sociologique c'est assez dramatique ça a
été une oeuvre civilisationnel mais
c'est en train de se retourner
lentement mais sûrement voilà je pense
que on aura l'occasion d'en discuter
l asaph active les architectes
urbanistes vous avez enseigné à l'école
d'architecturé de danse y est à l'école
nationale supérieure des beaux-arts de
paris vous avez crever que
et plus exactement la revue
d'architecturé amc en 1967 vous avez été
vice-président du plan de construction
de 88 à 92 en ce moment vous travaillez
sur le musée de l'espace de shanghai est
ce que pour vous la ville est encore
l'avenir de l'humanité
je pense que la ville est le creuset de
la démocratie alors la question que vous
posez c'est est-ce que la démocratie a
un avenir
je le crois je le crois très clairement
la ville est une culture la ville et est
une esthétique
une façon de vivre ensemble mais je
rajouterais à votre question est ce que
c'est la ville dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui ou y at il une évolution
possible et je parierais pour une
évolution de cette ville alors on va
voir ce que vous entendez chaque cas par
une évolution parce que c'est pas
forcément la même chose mais d'abord sur
ta vous montrer des publicités parce que
quand on prend le métro à paris on en
voit beaucoup et sont toutes les
publicités qui nous incite à quitter la
ville quitté paris à aller s'installer
en province à aller s'installer dans des
villes plus petites
là on voit ces particuliers à
particuliers qui fait cette campagne
si on a envie de quitter paris on
pourrait s'installer ailleurs plus près
de la nature
il ya là c'est la ville d'alès qui nous
invite nous les franciliens aller nous
installer dans le gard où on serait plus
près de la nature où on vivrait plus
agréablement
est ce que est ce que guillaume fabio
faburel est ce que ces publicités vous
semblent aller dans votre bain aller
dans votre sens et ce qu'elles sont
particulièrement adaptés à ce moment que
nous traversons je sais pas si elles
vont dans mon sens par contre elle
confirme quelque chose qui est engagée
d'assez longue date
maintenant c'est à dire que là le désir
des grandes villes que
le souhait d'y vivre et considérablement
questionner remis en cause
voilà ça remonte en fait pour des
grandes villes un plusieurs décennies
alors effectivement du coup le
confinement à la pandémie ont été une
catharsis ont mis en lumière ont dévoilé
cette réalité là mais que l'ensemble des
observateurs avaient déjà plus ou moins
pointé quant à des villes petites ou
moyennes qui ferait campagne dans le
métro parisien
elle n'attendait que ça en fait voilà
pour pouvoir développer un marketing
territorial et j'insiste sur un point ça
sera certainement un élément de
discussion c'est que comment dire les
grandes villes se sont construits se
sont construites pardon au détriment
justement d'autres my territoriale des
petites et des villes moyennes
voilà on a un déséquilibre territorial
qui est tout à fait majeur ça c'est
historique ça remonte aux deux siècles
écoulés et qu' il ya une forme de
revanche aussi qui peut se jouer
derrière cette chose là en tout cas il
ya un dessin de rééquilibrage
généralisée de relocalisation de
réimplantation de réinstallation et je
crois que c'est c'est quelque chose qui
est engagée dans les désirs dans les
croyances dans les envies après la
matérialité et passer à l'acte c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué parce que ça
pose la question de nos existences du
rapport à notre travail du rapport à
l'éducation aux enfants aux dieux
d'habiter mais néanmoins le coup est
parti et du coup on en attendait pas
moins des petites villes et des villes
moyennes qu'elle fasse campagne qu'elle
cherche à faire venir
on est quand même sur un modèle qui est
assez assez assez assez unitaire entre
les grands des villes moyennes qui est
celui de la concurrence territoriale
d'attirer en fait des populations à
cette fin là donc je sais pas si cela va
dans le sens de ma thèse qui d'ailleurs
n'est pas ma thèse qui est plutôt le
produit des observations que l'on a pu
faire
mais effectivement la pandémie n'a qatar
si on a un peu décomplexée cette envie
de changer un peu de vie et d'habiter un
peu différemment à ty écologiquement et
humainement un peu plus décentes
voilà donc la campagne ou le métro en a
été le relais iconique ou esthétique
mais je suis pas sûr que ce soit ça qui
est déclenché des foules entières le
désir était déjà là carlos moreno le
désir ce désir là vous l'avez constaté
est ce qu'il faut le combattre ou au
contraire
l'encourager et dire aux gens vous
écoutez si vous avez envie allez-y non
il n'ya pas des combats à mener par
rapport au désir il ya ce qu'on appelle
les croyances des désirs et les
intentions donc le désir a toujours
présent de healesville beaucoup plus un
seul humaine ne révise d'années que l'on
puisse et avoir un mode de vie qui soit
et autrement par rapport à ce qu'on a
connu
est ce qu'aujourd'hui la vraie question
qui se pose elle n'est pas le désir mais
est dans le fait qu est-ce qui est
aujourd'hui à notre portée moi je dis
dans mon livre que aujourd'hui et les
grandes villes qui ont connu au niveau
mondial mais les ennuis connus en france
sont en fait et c'est un fait
incontournable
je parle des droits de cité j'ai dit que
plutôt que se concentraient sur la
problématique dont côté si la ville
existait encore
c'est juste en fait incontournable
utilisé en introduction il faut parler
des droits de cité donc qu on va remonte
à ristote l'animal politique donc la
cité les polices la chose publique et
donc mon travail a été de imaginer
comment même des villes à très grande
échelle pouvait être transformé en
elle-même pour retrouver cette proximité
est heureuse que nous avons perdu et
donc quand nous avons mobilisé six
choses qui nous paraissent essentiels
trouver quelle que soit la taille de la
ville un habitat digne un travail de
centraliser à proximité la manière de
faire des courses d'une manière la plus
la plus courte c'est impossible
accéder à sa santé physique et mentale
accéder à la culture l'éducation et
avoir des loisirs et d'insignes nature
avec lesquels nos soins réconcilier et
mon combat où l'appel et ce à la ville
de proximité la ville des quarts d'heure
c'est de pouvoir rpt est considérée des
seychelles humaine y compris dans les
grandes villes y compris des grandes
métropoles dans lesquels on peut tisser
des liens d'humanité on peut pas faire
comme annonce comme alphonse allais
quatre des dix et il va falloir qu'on
construise les villes à la campagne donc
un rééquilibrage territorial assurée par
rapport à une moyenne effectivement il
ya d'une nouvelle armature territoriales
mais paris lyon marseille
ils vont passer vider des inspecteurs
pour devenir des villes moyennes
donc on part de ces faits métropolitan
il existe je l'avais fait cette émission
il ya sept ans il n'y avait aucune
métropole aujourd'hui la vendeuse et
même des villes moyennes
et comme on peut évoquer tour par
exemple sont aujourd'hui des métropoles
donc oui il ya un fait de
métropolisation parce qu'il ya un fait
mondiale également de vie urbaine
le coc vide est venu rabattre les cartes
mais je dirais plus dans la manière qu
en poupe comme on peut humaniser ces
villes là c'est pour ça que avec mes
équipes de recherche nous travaillons
sur cette proximité et reuze quelle que
soit la taille de la ville d'ain et
qu'elle ait fait sa vie alain sarfati à
la fois sur la campagne de publicité que
j'ai montré ce désir est ce que c'est un
véritable désir ou c'est juste l'envié
d'avoir une maison de campagne qui se
paie steria liseret donc chez les chez
les urbains aujourd'hui et puis on va en
venir à la ville de la proximité est ce
que c'est vraiment ça l'avenir de l'est
de la ville moi ce qui me semble de plus
important c'est d'avoir le choix
choisir de vivre complètement à la
campagne de vivre dans une ville moyenne
de vivre dans une grande métropole ou au
centre d'une grande ville
c'est avoir le choix et ce contre quoi
je m'insurge
c'est cette notion d' équilibre alors
pour des raisons sur lesquelles il est
difficile de ceux de comment dirais-je
de s'étendre tout de suite
l'urbanisme depuis un siècle n'a eu de
cesse que de chercher à rééquilibrer
c'est tout on rééquilibre le
développement se fait à l'ouest non
c'est pas possible c'est naturel donc il
faut qu'on aille à l'est le marché veut
que alors on fait le contraire
voilà c'est exactement ça ça c'est
l'urbanisme c'est prendre en permanence
le contre-pied moyennant quoi on est
dans la situation dans laquelle bush
homme des villes qui reste le chaotique
pour une raison très simple c'est que on
a refusé de regarder la réalité en face
on l'a refusé de regarder les véritables
mutations qui ont été engendrées par
l'intrusion fantastique de la vitesse
depuis depuis 150 ans dans nos villes
elles l ont été destructrice c'est sur
les deux vitesses la vitesse verticale
celle d'aider les ascenseurs la vitesse
horizontale
au lieu de ça eh bien on cherche
toujours à faire le contraire c'est à
dire que les villes se développent
on cherche pas à comprendre comment et
comment on peut les orienter
on cherche ailleurs regardez 1947 un
jean-françois gravier écrire un livre
qui à un titre magnifique paris le
désert français 70 ans
on en est toujours au même point on en
est à faire des politiques aujourd'hui
de coeur de ville après avoir fait les
politiques de métropoles d'équilibré
politique de ville moyenne des
politiques toutes les politiques ont été
inventés et aujourd'hui bon on saupoudre
alors je trouve tout à fait légitime que
les villes moyennes cherche aujourd'hui
à se remettre dans le jeu
non seulement je trouve ça légitime mais
je soutiens et je travaille moi même
précisément sur ce sujet mais ça n'est
pas en disant aux gens venez habiter
dans la périphérie
vous allez doublé multiplier le nombre
de gilet jaune
c'est d'abord en se posant la question
de savoir comment on réindustraliser ce
pays
comment on produit du bien commun
comment on met en relation le centre de
ces villes moyennes avec les
périphériques qui sont complètement
déstructurée comment elles sont
désorientés aujourd'hui et donc c'est de
façon pragmatique qu'il faut ville par
ville commencé par dire voilà la vision
que l'on a de l'avenir
voilà le vrai projet que l'on a pour
vous et vous pouvez éventuellement
envisager de venir
mais si vous leur dites aujourd'hui on
est capable de faire des lotissements
vous allez venir vous en faites des gens
qui à l'évidence seront des malheureux
des oubliés de la société et des gens
qui seront perdus ou qui chercheront à
revenir en ville dans les vingt ou
trente années qui vont venir
guillaume faburel à chaque fois c'est
vrai qu'on a donné comme porte de sortie
aux habitants des grandes villes alors
que ce soit la banlieue où les zones
pavillonnaires ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui la france périphérique au
fond se terminer par des revendications
et un sentiment d'injustice
qu'est ce que vous répondez est sa
banque il ya deux siècles de privilèges
des grandes villes et la métropolisation
parce que contrairement à ce que l'on
collé gland dire des métropoles existe
depuis belle lurette
c'est par un label d'une réforme
territoriale qui entérine un processus
de très longue haleine qui en fait la
démesure urbaine la grandeur urbaine et
deuxième élément je vivre à la sagacité
tout le monde sait que ce produit
historique de la grandeur urbaine ça
s'appelle du capitalisme voilà c'est
quelque chose qui renvoient à des
intérêts économiques à l'employabilité
l'offre d'activités à la concentration
du capital dans des endroits et ça s'est
fait au détriment des périphéries et des
campagnes
voilà les métropoles on met trop colisée
l'entièreté des espaces y compris les
espaces dits de nature qui sont en fait
une agriculture intensive
conventionnelle et qui produisent
toujours plus toujours plus toujours
plus pour alimenter les polarités
urbaines qui ne cesse de grossir
donc après on peut s'étonner qu'il ya
des mouvements de révolte de rebellions
on parlait de gilet jaune ya deux
secondes avec des propos peu amènes
peut-être moi je ne serai pas de cette
culture là ce sont les périphéries qui
commence un peu à se poser la question
de l'égalité du traitement et de la
justice qui se joue derrière mais pour
revenir au sujet je crois qu'on est
dedans on néanmoins le fait que des gens
veulent quitter quelque chose qui ne
fait de ça qui fait de moins en moins
sens la grandeur l'illimitation la
démesure l'accélération des vies la
suffocation la saturation la
surstimulation voilà ce que sont devenus
les grandes villes voilà ce qu'est le
fait métropolitain aujourd'hui et dans
ce que disait carlos moreno j'ai pas
entendu le terme d'écologie
il n'y a pas de possibilité de faire
vertus écologiquement lorsqu'on a
dépassé un certain niveau de peuplement
parce que pour vivre tous ensemble à
plus de 200 à 300 milles il faut tout
artificialisés faut tout bétonner faut
faire venir de très très loin sont
mécanisés les campagnes et du coup soit
retiré les bras des campagnes les m
il sait exactement ce que le capitalisme
urbain a produit sur les deux derniers
siècles
voilà ce qui me semble être peut-être la
rupture civilisationnel qui se joue
aujourd'hui au delà des campagnes dans
le métro de alès ou de kaw carlos moreno
non je suis pas du tout d'accord et
c'est tout à fait intéressant de des
pouvoirs un débat entre donc au
générique elle la question est beaucoup
plus en profondeur la problématique
c'est le productivisme
j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter les cartes
et les cosmonautes à prague avant les
révolutions de velours
j'ai eu l'occasion de visiter des grands
complexes de logements à moscou j'ai
passé du temps à oulan-bator comment
vous pouvez imaginez donc que vous
là-bas torse wade soit devenue l'une des
villes les plus polluées au monde à
l'étang dans tous les pays dans lesquels
on à la densité de population au mètre
carré donc voilà la moindre dans
lesquelles la qualité de vie de nomade
avec qui j'ai invité était est
absolument extraordinaire
il ya une question qui les productivisme
que ça soit donc aujourd'hui exacerbée
par un capitalisme
d'autre part on est un phénomène nouveau
qui évoluent dans les années 2000 avec
l'internet nouvelles technologies
incrémenté ce que j'appelle l'urbanisme
grégaire c'est à dire que j'ai une
nouvelle technologie on venu créer une
surcouche dans les fers métropolitan qui
maintient donc au cette envie de vivre
en ville et qui est porté d'ailleurs
beaucoup par la jeunesse
les études statistiques ont pu le
montrer le fait que cette utilisation de
la messagerie instantanée des réseaux
dans l'événementiel agrège davantage au
niveau du fait urbain donc l'écologie
elle n'est pas uniquement vivre à la
campagne quand nous nous avons la ville
de proximité nous avons quatre piliers
une écologie pour vivre de manière
décarbonés et il faut saisir les moyens
de le développer et la problématique des
rêves et urbaine et la manière comment
on fait usage de la ville et comment
réconcilient une manière de vivre par
rapport à deux composantes majeures qui
sont le temps et l'espace
ce qui était réalité c'est qu'on a perdu
le ton parce que finalement les jo ils
vivent en ville plutôt pour perdre leur
vie pour la gagner pourquoi ce que nous
ont même
c'est la création entre l'espace le
temps parce que l'espace urbain il s'est
perdu au détriment de ce qu'on appelle
donc au la promiscuité 1 sachant qu' on
peut parfaitement de développer il y en
a plein d'exemples
est ce que l'on appelle la densité la
densité organique recherché naître dans
la préface de mon livre il dit la
densité est une vertu
là où la distance est en vis et donc
nous pouvons développer une densité
organique urbaine et nous sommes même
obligés de les faire parce qu'il y aura
pas de baguette magique qui va enlever
les vis pour les mettre à la campagne et
il n'y a pas de l'écologie et de la
ruralité qui permettra de donner une
continuité à la manière de vivre donc au
aujourd'hui et ce sont donc deux
nouveaux paradigmes qui se pose donc on
applique également dans des villes des
tailles diverses
et pour lequel on cherche ce que la paye
une proximité heureuse basé sur quatre
piliers l'écologie et la proximité pour
explorer les ressources que nous avons
des manières donko polymorphe la
solidarité pour créer du lien social et
la participation citoyenne pour changer
la manière comme on fabrique david
comeau fabrique des relations sociales
de la ville autour de quelque chose
canin a évoqué qui est le bien commun la
problématique aujourd'hui c'est avoir
des politiques urbaines pour lequel les
biens communs soient au coeur de la
manière comment tu proposes la manière
des bureaux dans la ville et c'est ça
qui aujourd'hui et est au coeur des
transformations urbaines que nous
voulons faire je dis bien des
transformations urbaines puisque les
villes existent elles existeront lire
malgré nous alain sarfati vous avez
construit dans le monde entier vous avez
derrière vous on voit l'opéra de paris
paris qui est une des villes où la
densité urbaine est la plus forte en on
s'en rend pas compte parce que c'est
très bien fait finalement mai mais c'est
densité comme on en connaît que en asie
quasiment 1
est ce que vous y croyez à cette ville
de proximité est ce que ça vous semble
réalisable ou est ce que c'est une
utopie
à vos yeux c'est pas du tout une utopie
où l'on la vie paris nous offre
justement cette chose extraordinaire qui
est cet exemple
de pouvoir avoir effectivement à un
quart d'heure les écoles les commerces
tout les toutes les activités de
proximité bon c'est tout c'est à part ça
on peut on n'a pas le louvre un quart
d'heure pour tout le monde mais la vie y
est je pense tout à fait facile et est
heureuse mais ce que je voudrais c'est
insisté sur deux points
on en a parlé le bien commun je crois
véritablement que ce que la charte
d'athènes ce que le le fonctionnalisme
nous a fait perdre de vue c'est
précisément ce qu'on appelle le bien
commun dire cet espace sur lequel nous
nous rencontrons vous savez aujourd'hui
demain les terrasses vont réouvrir et
c'est le l'attend là plus la plus
importante de la population tout le
monde se dit ah vivement que les
terrasses rouvre qu'on puisse enfin se
retrouver et c'est ça qui est de mon
point de vue le le poids le plus
important quand on parle de la ville
c'est de pouvoir se rencontrer
alors si on reprend ce qui a été dit
précédemment et qu'on regarde un petit
peu plus près les choses on se rend
compte de ce qu on est dans une
problématique qui est de la
concentration d'un côté de la dispersion
de l'autre il s'agit pas de bétonner
d'un côté et de ne pas bétonner de
l'autre si on disperse ça va être encore
pire
on va avoir encore plus de relations à
créer on va avoir encore plus de deux
lotissements qui vont se faire donc le
vrai obstacle aujourd'hui c'est comment
réussir à construire de façon danse en
ayant sicot logiquement l'impression que
dans le fond on est dans quelque chose
qui est acceptable
eh bien nous avons derrière nous une
catastrophe qui est ce qui s'est fait
dans les années 60 70
c'est à dire des immeubles qui sont
visuellement danse alors que la réelle
de la densité réel et trois quatre cinq
fois inférieure à celle du paris intra
muros
donc on est devant vraiment quelque
chose qu'il faut observer de façon
sérieuse avant de se lancer dans des
comment dirais-je des théories qui
risque de conduire encore plus
l'explosion de cette ville qui qui a
besoin de personne pour pour pour
éclater
envie de dire que le vrai sujet
aujourd'hui pour moi est de regarder ce
qui se passe et dire eh bien écoutez
regardez
prenons un exemple très simple le
problème du triangle de gonesse le
triangle de gonesse
les gens se sentaient écharpe et parce
qu'il y avait un grand centre commercial
qui a laissé faire et puis on l'a
abandonné et aujourd'hui on va faire
l'équivalent du rungis nord très bien
mais qu'est ce que ça a à voir avec le
grand paris
en quoi ce secteur va être va-t-il être
reliée à paris est ce que quelqu'un est
en train de se dire mais dans le fond
paris c'était exceptionnel parce que
c'est une ville qui est enserrée dans
son périphérique mais qui est une ville
rayonnante alors rendre à un nouveau
rayonnante réfléchissons sur ce qui se
passe entre le triangle de gonesse et le
centre de paris revoyant ce qui se passe
sur le bourget regardant ce qu'on peu
réaménagée dans les dix ans qui viennent
sur la route nationale 2 et à ce moment
là on aura produit à nouveau du bien
commun au lieu de ça eh bien on traite
les choses de façon séparée sans qu'on
réussisse à comprendre quelle est la
logique
et quel est le laury's on qu'on se
constitue voilà ma réponse à cette
question ne jouons pas avec la densité
ne faisons pas peur aux gens ne leur
proposons pas des situations qui seront
ingérable parce qu'ils sont obligés
d'avoir leur leur automobile
elles auront beau être électrique et
bien il faudra en avoir trois ou quatre
par famille pour pouvoir aller
véritablement chacun faire ses activités
faburel dans 2 minutes 30 c'est la pause
nous interrompt près mais je ne rendrai
la parole après l isi je trouve ça très
prescriptif et injonctif que de se
mettre à la place du désir ou de ce que
les volontés ont pu exprimer
en fait je fais mon adresse c'est
l'intérêt du débat la contradiction on
est confronté aux mêmes réalités on les
interprète pas de la même manière donc
voilà c'est la richesse tant mieux mais
moi je j'ai du mal à voir de quel avenir
nous parlons écologiquement
on est quand même engagé dans une crise
écologique qui est un désastre dans une
extermination croissante du vivant et
les villes et leurs artificialité joue
un rôle tout à fait considérable dans
cette réalité là donc quels sont les
écologies en concurrence faut-il
continuer à technicisé nos vies de telle
manière à faire quelques économies par
là mais d'un autre côté de ne plus avoir
de contact direct de ne plus faire
directement de sa main de ne plus mettre
en pratique le ralentissement qui
traverse de plus en plus d' enquête
sociologique c'est en train de remonter
en fait est ce que les vies urbaines et
métropolitaines sont le produit du bon
vouloir de l' expertise et des savoirs
installés ou entendons-nous
véritablement ce que seraient les
mutations que je qualifie mois
d'anthropologie qu'un dans des besoins
alors je suis d'accord
les besoins sont un peu fantasmé l'accès
à la nature qui serait comment dire
quelque chose de magique un retour à un
état de nature qui n'a jamais existé oui
à beaucoup d'illusions idéalités de
fantasmes mais néanmoins il ya bien une
rupture paradigmatique qui est celle du
devenir planétaire de la question
écologique et les réponses qui nous sont
proposés par l'urbain aujourd'hui c'est
de continuer à accélérer dans la roue
voilà de continuer à développer ses
vortex parce que ce sont effectivement
des vortex qui ont parlé de vue triangle
de gonesse le triangle de gonesse
aujourd'hui c'est la bétonisation à
l'artificialisation du front urbain nord
qui a été préservé par des nuisances
sonores et la proximité de roissy et du
bourget dont qui a gardé en friche des
terres qui étaient cultivées et qu'on va
aujourd'hui artificialisés pour
continuer à faire grandir le grand paris
et continuer à peser dans le concert et
dans la compétition internationale d'une
ville monde qui s'appelle paris ça
s'appelle la démesure on est à la fin
d'un cycle ce cycle là c'est celui du
béton du parpaing comme lingots du
pauvre je crois sincèrement que sans
pour autant aller en campagne
riri avec son suv pour réclamer sa 5 g
je ne crois pas que la majorité des gens
et cette envie débordante là je vous dis
des enquêtes montrent qu'il ya un besoin
de faire différemment de ralentir un peu
d'avoir un autre rapport à l'emploi à la
mobilité à l'éducation
il n ya peut-être quelque chose qui
pourrait rééquilibrer en cas remettre un
peu de décence et de mesure dans notre
rapport à l'urbain aujourd'hui voilà moi
ce qui m'intéresse je vous interromps je
vous donnerai la parole juste après la
sympathie on fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après
[Musique]
les grandes villes sont elles encore
l'avenir de l'humanité on repose débat
avec carlos moreno l'auteur de droit de
cité de la ville monde à la ville du
quart d'heure avec guillaume faburel qui
publie pour en finir avec les grandes
villes et avec l'architecte urbaniste à
la sarthe ati je vous donne la parole à
alain sarfati vouliez répondra à
guillaume faburel je voudrais revenir
sur un point qui est celui du choix
je ne veux pas qu'on on oppose la grande
ville la ville moyenne ou petite ville
dont on sait pas très bien quelle est
qu'elles sont le quelles sont les
limites
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
que on puisse choisir que la vie ne soit
pas une succession de renoncement ça
c'est d'abord ce qui est très important
la deuxième chose va porter sur l'idée
qu'après tout il faudrait quitter les
villes aller vers des petites villes
parce qu'elles en ont besoin et on
oublie on oublie les les raisons pour
lesquels existent des grandes villes et
les raisons pour lesquelles ces
concentrations se sont faites alors il
faut peut-être rappeler faut peut-être
simplement dire que l'origine de la
ville
c'est d'abord assurer la sécurité et
quand on sera dans les petites villes où
le ou abandonnés dans un village eh bien
on se posera la question de savoir
combien de temps m les pompiers pour
arriver où l'on roule en où l'ambulance
mais laissons ça de côté
la sécurité le marché le marché
le regarder le la possibilité de choisir
effectivement quand on est dans une dans
une petite ville et bien que disent les
gens ils disent ça on n'a pas ce qu'on
pourrait avoir dans dans à lyon ou à
toulouse ou à bordeaux
donc ils n'ont pas le choix dans le
marché et puis la troisième chose c'est
simplement pouvoir disparaître dans la
foule pouvoir exister regardez les
autres
simplement j'ai envie de dire la culture
de la ville puisque c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé
et bien c'est de pouvoir s'asseoir à la
terrasse d'un café et regarder passer
les gens mais bien quand on sera dans
ainsi dans une petite ville et qu'on
aura vu passer quatre fois les mêmes
gens dans la matinée on se dira comme
on était mieux sur le cours mirabeau à
aix ou sur la place stanislas à nancy
c'est ça il n'y a pas une ville idéale
il y a à chaque fois des problèmes qui
sont attachés à l'échelle de la ville et
c'est une erreur que de penser qu'il y à
une solution unique et qui va être
appliqué sur l'ensemble du territoire
je crois que on a la chance d'avoir un
pays qui est un pays urbain à laquelle
il y a les plus belles villes du monde
parce que c'est vrai parce que c'est
vrai que paris est une des plus belles
villes du monde que toulouse est une
ville magnifique que que aix en provence
n'a pas son équivalent et que dans six à
une d aussi une des plus des plus belles
places qui existe et dieu sait si j'en
ai visité beaucoup donc je crois qu'il
faut garder ça présent à l'esprit c'est
du patrimoine je veux terminer en disant
juste une chose si les villes étaient
aussi détestable que ce que l'on dit
alors il n'y aurait pas ce tourisme
urbain qui fait que de hautes de plus en
plus les gens choisissent pour aller
passer leurs vacances ils choisissent
d'aller en ville ils vont à prague à
copenhague à budapest à rome à milan à
barcelone où ou à madrid
regardez les jeunes qui ont été
interrogés ces derniers jours
eh bien ils sont partis se détendre à
madrid ou à barcelone
alors je veux pas accepter l'idée que la
solution unique serait la décroissance
parce que derrière ça aussi hier du
malthusianisme et il faut le faire
apparaître il faut dire si vous voulez
que la population décroît ce que
l'économie décroissent alors dites-le
mais dit de façon claire et sans avoir
besoin d'afficher une haine de la ville
j'adore les villes et je crois vraiment
que c'est le bien le plus précieux qu'en
effet il ya un tout de même des réponses
vous donne la parole tout de suite
carlos moreno c'est à vous je faisais
pour poser la question derrière il ya
tout de même des réponses que l'on
retrouve dans toutes les grandes villes
par exemple la piétonnisation la maire
de paris anne hidalgo veut piétonniser
quatre arrondissements
on voit bien la piétonnisation c'est
partout et ça produit toujours les mêmes
quartiers partout dans le monde
la piétonisation ça produit les mêmes
quartiers avec les mêmes boutiques de
verroterie pour les touristes avec bon
mois ce que j'appelle l'ennui yoruba
mais enfin ça c'est un truc personnel en
tout cas les quartiers piétons c'est
tous les mêmes absolument partout ça
produit aussi l' autre réponse sur les
mêmes le mobilier urbain le mobilier
urbain est beaucoup moins beau dans les
grandes villes est aujourd'hui qu'il ne
l'était il ya un siècle
c'est même sans comparaison on pourrait
dire la vidéosurveillance elle est
absolument partout
vous parliez de de pouvoir être un
inconnu dans la foule
combien de temps ça va encore durer est
ce que on ne pourra encore être un
inconnu dans la foule dans une grande
ville quand tu auras des caméras un
repas dansant spécial un peu partout
j'ai l'impression que ces réponses à
quoi on pourrait ajouter la verdure les
murs les murs de verdure on a
l'impression que c'est bas c'est la
réponse qu'on trouvait et peut-être avec
la ville du quart d'heure alors c'est
peut-être tout les mêmes concepts
qu'aujourd'hui toutes les grandes villes
du monde ont l'air de partager venait
pas ce sentiment j'ai prédit une carlos
moreno non non et moi je pense que est
en fait si on veut raisonné et par
rapport à à 7 à ceux de venir de la
ville et on parle de des grandes villes
ça ne sera jamais à nos positions par
rapport à l'or en réalité on peut pas
assimiler d'écologie uniquement à la
ruralité
je pense qu est-ce qui est au coeur et
frédéric voulait résumer plutôt assez
bien avec cette uniformisation que vous
décrivez qui est qui est juste c'est
plutôt et quels sont les modes de vie
auxquels nous sommes confrontés
quel est le mode de production que le
mode de consommation et quelles sont nos
centres d'intérêts comme nous vivons
quelque part est ce que vous décrivez
l'arc antillais les rues piétonnes avec
ses ailes commercial donné que le trouve
à gauche et à droite de la rue que l'on
soit à paris à barcelone ou à bogota
les mêmes enseignes qui vendent les
mérites des produits parce que nous
sommes liés à un mode de production mode
de consommation qui de manière massive
nous entraîne d'ailleurs dans la
production de beaucoup d'objets inutiles
et l'achat des beaucoup d'objets
inutiles aussi et qui sont donc on va
dire au coeur de ce qu'on appelle un
troupeau scène c'est à dire dans la
destruction de leurs ressources eau par
cette espèce d des folies de produire et
de consommer des choses dont on n'a pas
vraiment besoin
donc quand nous raisonnons aujourd'hui
sur le combat que nous menons c'est un
combat urbain par rapport à nos modes de
vie quand nous raisonnons par rapport au
bien commun c'est pour identifier
donc qu'est-ce que il faut préserver
l'air l'eau la nature la biodiversité
mais une culture urbaine qu'ils soient
liés aux racines de l'endroit où nous
vivons quand on redécouvre nos racines
dans un vieux con paris dans une
commande meurtre mais également dans
plein d'autres lieux on peut assister à
un phénomène de ce que nous appelons
donc la taupe ofili c'est à dire l'amour
pour les lieux et l'allumeur corps les
lieux et ces rappels et même dans ces
cas là à bogota à barcelone à madrid ou
à montréal
la taupe ophélie ces îles nouvelle
urbanité une nouvelle culture de
l'urbain notre risque c'est que
aujourd'hui avec de nouvelles
technologies on assiste à ce que
j'appelle les miroirs flou c'est à dire
cette espèce des couches qui est venu se
superposer aux urbains par rapport à la
culture de l'internet et qui crée cette
homogénéité et donc notre combat c'est
pour retrouver des racines de la ville
dans lesquels chacun peut faire sa
découverte qu'on vient d'ici aucun bien
d'ailleurs assister à un nouveau
tourisme dont côté nature différente et
que nous fait donc comprendre que la
ville a des richesses qu'elle peut
offrir et kate à ces cas là la
végétalisation c'est pas une mode en soi
mais c'est une manière d'être aussi un
rapport avec les autres et je pense que
il ya une grande tendance qui en transe
a désigné aujourd'hui donc pas
uniquement pour rendre piétonne
certaines certains endroits de la ville
mais pour ré découvrir d'autres manières
de vivre qui peuvent créer donc au cette
altérité et on le voit aujourd'hui comme
un point de rupture qui est je pense
capable de le repenser lié avec ce que
les urbanistes suédois jan guen appelle
donc au la ville à l'échelle humaine est
ce que les italiens ont appelé el topo
de la chip donc le temps de la ville est
ce que nous nous appellons donc on avait
le dit quart d'heure et est ce qui a
produit des lieux très agréable à vivre
malgré la densité qui veut que qui ont
peu à voir parce que on a cette espèce
de de ressentis d'humanité et c'est que
nous voulons aujourd'hui chercher un
sachant que cet urbanisme était
réversible j'ai souligné d'un cinq
continents qui les marines gâtine
j'allais quitter il ya 40 ans il ya 40
ans il y avait 70 % des requêtes 30%
d'urbain aujourd'hui à 20% de ruraux et
80% durban c'est les contenus les plus
urbanisées au monde
on peut pas y avoir aujourd'hui un
combat pour retrouver la ruralité 10 à
40 ans notre combat aujourd'hui c'est
pour humaniser ses villes pour retrouver
les quartiers pour retrouver donc cette
taupe ophélie pour retrouver l'amour et
l'envi des vivres et pour créer des
contre-pouvoirs locaux dans lesquels on
relocalise 1 crée de l'emploi
il y en a mais une démocratie et qui
peut transformer les choses
on l'a vu encore récemment au chili à
santiago et commença à tourner parce que
il ya eu effectivement il rencontre d'el
urbain avec son humanité et je pense qu
est ce qu on a perdu et ça on le
retrouve d'un habile et ce n'est pas un
combat que mène à la campagne faburel
moi je écouter nos échanges pour moi
réparer les rapports humains c'est
d'abord réparer les rapports aux vivants
et je suis pas sûr que la densité
l'artificialité le béton mais c'est
mécanique c'est physique soit le
meilleur allié pour pouvoir restaurer
des liens de respect de dignité de
décence dans une situation qui est
écologiquement quand même dramatique
alors maintenant sur la question des
ruralités des campagnes moi j'entends
les propos qui sont tenus mais j'entends
un discours quand même qui est très
disqualifiant à l'endroit des ruralités
des campagnes culturellement humainement
écologiquement et qui en fait le produit
historique 1 du choix politiques et
économiques qui ont été faits sur les
siècles écoulés de privilégier pour
notre émancipation pour l'intérêt
économique de tous nous regrouper en un
même endroit de venir nous agglomérés et
continuer par nos désirs fabriqués à
faire grossir et et grandir les villes
et ce temps là à mon avis il doit être
interrogé cette histoire là doit être
mise en débat parce que les enjeux alors
j'entends un qu' il pourrait y avoir des
recettes de ci de là
frédéric taddeï parlait de
l'uniformisation de standardisation mais
qui croit un instant que des fermes en
aqua pony ou en hydroponique des
toitures végétalisées que des mobilités
douces telles que l'accès au vélo qui
est une politique de classe 1 soyons
clair parce que quand même pour rappel
vivre à paris c'est plus de 10000 euros
du mètre carré à l'acquisition c'est pas
pour toutes les bourses
qui peut croire sincèrement que ces
recettes là que l'on trouve maintenant
dans toutes les boîtes à outils des
villes mondes et leurs déclinaisons
métropolitaine auront la hauteur et la
dignité d'inverser le forçage
généralisée de l'entièreté des
écosystèmes là moi c'est une question de
mode de vie de style de vie mais je
constate que les modes les styles et les
formes de vie finalement s'écologise
dans leur désir bien plus vite que les
discours que l'on entend assez
régulièrement et que les recettes et des
boîtes à outils qui s'uniformise
elle-même pour s'appliquer de manière
homogène standardisés dans l'entièreté
des grandes villes ça serait peut-être
bien d'inverser 1 2 déjà le flux puisque
historiquement on a vidé les campagnes
de leurs bras pour les mettre dans les
villes et ben il faut rendre les bras
mais avec d'autres cerveaux très
certainement parce que dans les villes
on a désappris on n'a pas appris un
certain nombre de choses qui pourraient
nous permettre de faire autrement
rapport au vivant
par l'autonomie notamment mais il ya une
inversion qui est à opérer en tout cas
il ya une rupture paradigmatique et
anthropologique
excusez moi pour des grands airs main
mais c'est la fin du débat je me laisse
aller
il ya quelque chose qu'il a me semble
fondamental hauteur à condition que le
débat aille bien à ce niveau là la
grandeur est une des mesures
cette démesure est en train de créer un
écocide on ne peut pas décemment
considérer que continuer à densifier
artificialisés sont de quelconques
vertus écologiques pour notre humanité
voilà ce que j'ai lu à la fare faty moi
je suis une seule chose à dire tout de
suite c'est que on a pas on a pas on n'a
pas retiré les les gens de la campagne
et aujourd'hui on ne va pas les envoyer
à la campagne je pense que les gens
décideront cc c'est quand même un peu
curieux théoriquement comme comme façon
de prendre façon de considérer les
choses
je voudrais revenir sur un point sur
celui de la rue piétonne c'est assez
intéressant parce que il se trouve que
j'ai j'ai fait la rue piétonne rue
principale de lyon qui s'appelle la rue
de république dont l'a rendue piétonne
et on a constaté immédiatement que le
chiffre d'affaires de cette rue avait
augmenté mais qui avait une saveur
engendré une mutation du commerce c'est
à dire que des consommer à ralentir la
circulation à la piétonniser et bien le
commerce mute et donc c'est exactement
ce qui est en train de se passer ce qui
va se passer sur les champs-elysées on
pourra mettre autant d'arbres qu'on veut
sur les champs-elysées si on empêche la
circulation de se faire normalement
eh bien on aura une une comment dirais
je sais pas une paupérisation mai
une banalisation effectivement de ce
commerce
on le sait et donc c'est de mon point de
vue une grave erreur que d'espérer que
tout le centre de paris sera sera
quasiment rendu piéton si ce qui est en
train de se jouer aujourd'hui c'est que
ce sont des politiques qui ne disent pas
leur nom et qui est qu'ils sont en train
de faire exploser le lot le seul ce qui
reste d'urbanité dans cette dans cette
ville pourquoi pas tout simplement parce
que c'est l'idéologie qui domine le le
projet et le projet n'est pas structurée
par une vision par une manière de se
dire dans le fond qu'est ce qu'on
cherche
qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qu'on veut le
bonheur des gens très bien et bien le
bonheur des gens ont là en ayant
justement des équipements hospitaliers
en ayant des équipements universitaires
en ayant des terrasses de cafés en ayant
des activités et des bureaux en ayant
une mixité que on a perdu de vue depuis
50 ans c'est à dire qu'on est incapable
aujourd'hui de dire on va faire un
quartier mixte
alors on fait des quartiers de logements
d'un côté des quartiers de bureaux de
l'autre ça c'est une catastrophe et que
ce soit des bills petite moyenne ou
grande halle à l'éclatement du
fonctionnalisme fait voler en éclats le
rêve d'une d'une urbanité retrouvable
voilà ce que j'ai à dire ce que ce que
je pense vraiment c'est que je reviens
pour la troisième fois dans ce dans ce
débat sur une chose qui est importante
c'est choisir et choisir en fonction de
la situation dans laquelle on est et pas
espérer que on va pouvoir réussir à
chasser les gens pour les envoyer par
des relais villes moyennes
parce que les villes moyennes ont
effectivement besoin de vivre et elles
ont besoin de retrouver
eh bien ce sont les villes moyennes
effectivement comme vous le disiez au
début de cette émission en faisant des
publicités en expliquant véritablement
pourquoi il faut venir chez elle
non pas parce qu'on va leur donner un
pavillon qui va bétonner
mais parce qu'elles vont trouver un
emploi parce qu'il va y avoir un niveau
de service parce que culturellement
elles sont elles vont apporter quelque
chose
alors là vraiment il y aura de bonnes
raisons pour que parce que l'excellence
du collège parce que le lys
et ce sera le meilleur de la région là
on ira à alès ou ailleurs mais si c'est
uniquement pour être dans un pavillon
qui va bétonner la périphérie d'alès qui
sera plus dans la périphérie d'une
grande ville mais la périphérie d'alès
alors c'est la catastrophe annoncée
voilà ce que j'avais à dire oui je
voudrais puisque je pense qu'on va
arriver bientôt à la fin
insister sur un point qui me paraît
crucial au delà du débat si on rend
piétons tel ou tel périmètre où au delà
du débat ce qu'on envoie les joints à la
campagne on a eu des pays dans lesquels
ils sont envoyés des forces des jeux à
la campagne on voit ce que ça a donné
bref il me semble qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans une phase où les politiques
urbaines
on peut réfléchir autour de ces notions
de la qualité de vie et la qualité de
vie sociétale de la qualité de vie
sociétale qui est traversée par la
jouissance des communs sur banc d'essai
commandons j'évoquais tout à l'heure
l'air l'eau l'utilisation mais également
accéder à des commerces de proximité
qu'ils soient garantis par les communs
donc ça existe dans plusieurs villes 1
donc le foncière de commerce qui
achètent des mètres carrés et les met à
disposition de locaux commerciaux qui
rien du str élise et qui donc ont ne
sont pas soumis à la gentrification
parce que ce sont des mètres carrés qui
sont loués en dessous de 2 des prix du
marché à sa liste à paris ça existe bien
existant à plein d'endroits donc la
qualité de vie sociétale et pour moi le
coeur d'une vraie politique urbaine et
elle elle est donc aujourd'hui multiples
les croisés nous avons fait une
recherche avec mon équipe donc on
appelle ça une anthologie urbaine qui
est basé sur six choses essentielles on
a parlé d habitat digne en appareils
travail on a parlé de pouvoir faire ses
courses hors des manières sel on a parlé
d' accéder à la santé d'accéder à
l'éducation à la culture et d'accéder
aux loisirs
nous considérons que dans la mesure où
il est capable d'offrir des périmètres
urbains dans lesquels on accède et la
manière la plus décarbonés possible ada
jouissance au max
man 2 6 fonction sociale urbaine d'une
manière pressante ciel ou utilisant des
nouvelles technologies automatiquement
on est en train de remonter la qualité
des vies avec trois indicateurs mon
bien-être personnel et le temps que j'ai
passé avec ma famille mes proches
un deuxième niveau qu'on appelle la
dictature des sociabilités le temps que
je passe avec mes voisins que je
découvre et avec des collègues de
travail avec moi des tensions et les
troisièmes niveaux qui est celui qu'on
appelle le thème de l'écologie c'est à
dire de vivre avec donc des actes le
plus décarbonés possible il ya une
altérité avec les gens que je ne connais
pas et donc que nous avons cette vision
de la ville dit quart d'heure à nous
sommes compacts
on appelle les territoires d'airé
demi-heure dans des zones à moyenne ou
faible densité
ces notions de haute qualité de vie
sociétale dans lesquels on veut croiser
ces 6es fonction sociale qu'on veut
offrir dans une proximité que nous
appelons heureuse avec des mobilités et
choisit quitter les mobilités obligé
quitter les grandes plaines d'hilarité
qui sont synonymes donc aux détresses et
des la dégradation de la qualité de vie
et donc devenir de sur des zones
piétonnes ou pas ça devient plutôt à un
corollaire par rapport à une
programmatique qui elle effectivement
est en rupture avec le mono
fonctionnalisme qui est un qui s'inscrit
donc on incite démarche plutôt des
individus polycentrique des villes dans
lesquelles on a des services on va dire
un peu transverse et dans lesquels on a
un garant qui est le commun sur banques
les biens communs qui par un robot
c'était la prix nobel d'économie des
premières femmes élues ne reste rome en
2009 et qui représente un acquis pour
l'humanité que l'un perdu est un conte
ne réinjecte au pas les biens communs
dans la gouvernance de la ville
à ce moment là beaucoup des choses qu'on
peut faire prendront de la voie des
productivisme
parce que finalement c'est sous le
productivisme que l'on continue
aujourd'hui à vivre je les dis
réconcilier les biens communs avec donc
une autre qualité de vie et sociétal
permet à ce moment de la dg ray
mieux c'est que nous avons aujourd'hui
dans nos villes pour le rendre une
échelle humaine dont nous avons
aujourd'hui besoin de plus que jamais
des hommes faburel il nous reste quatre
minutes c'est tout vous voulez dire que
j'ai fait recours
non mais le bien commun dont il est
question là c'est une empreinte
écologique de la ville de paris qui
représente 340 3 fois sa superficie dans
cet hiver ses besoins alimentaires
énergétiques et production de matériaux
en termes simples il faudrait que la
ville de paris et 343 fois c'est sûr si
sa superficie d'aujourd'hui pour
éventuellement prétendre à l'autonomie
voilà le bien commun dont nous héritons
avec la démesure urbaine le bien commun
donc il s'agit là c'est les 100
premières villes de france qui ont trois
jours d'autonomie alimentaire qui n'ont
strictement aucun stock et qui en fait
on mécanisée par leur mode de
fonctionnement l'entièreté des
territoires plus de 50 % de la surface
agricole utile en france pour nous
concentrer toujours plus mais ne plus
avoir la résilience ou la souveraineté
nécessaire donc se pose également la
question pour moi de la relocalisation
le bien commun dont il s'agit c'est
toulouse ou bordeaux qui en période de
canicule estivale ont eu 20 degrés de
température de 8 degrés supérieur aux
petites campagnes qui sont de mon point
de vue un peu disqualifié dans les
discours entendus les petites campagnes
de 30 à 40 km voilà le bien commun dont
nous héritons donc de quelques mains
s'agit-il
effectivement c'est celui qui a été
produit par le productivisme qui a été
rappelé mais de quel commun s'agit-il
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on est dans cette
situation écologique là et que le béton
comme en selle le japon vient de le
montrer est une arme de construction
massive en fait du capitalisme là pour
moi on est à on est à une dislocation
assez assez fondamental donc je veux
bien les sur ce qui nous serait commun
et quel bien il pourrait y avoir de
commun ça ne pourra pas se faire sans
restio n'est hélas je vais dans le sens
de mes collègues les systèmes de besoin
et la manière d'y répondre
ça ne pourra pas se faire sans
fondamentalement prendre vraiment au mot
ce qui semble arriver
dans plusieurs pays c'est à dire gens
disent que j'en parlais tout à l'heure
la question du ralentissement la
démesure et la limite commence à
travailler les esprits les gens se
posent la question du sens que les
villes urbaines métropolitaine ont
aujourd'hui
moi il me semble plus que nécessaire
vital à des fins écologiques que nous
nous posions collectivement la question
et dernier élément bien évidemment il
s'agit pas d'aller peuple et comme je
disais tout à l'heure avec son suv sa
sagesse sa piscine chauffée ou une
superficie pour le même prix démesuré du
logement non ça c'est les modes de vie
du présent mais il semble que à bas
bruit il y ait des signaux faibles
convergent pour dire qu' il pourrait y
avoir révolution on pourrait ou les
désirs qui s'annoncent sont des désirs
aussi de modération aussi de tempérance
la question c'est de savoir c'est est ce
qu'on met en pratique cette modération à
cette tempérance dans les espaces
artificialisés saturées sur stimuler en
mouvement incessant touristique chier
etc etc ou le fait de tout simplement
foulé la terre caresser des fougères
regarder un peu d'air brèche avoir un
rapport comment dire non romantiser un
non sens tu as semé à la nature mais de
retrouver simplement des espaces de
nature nous ferait justement nous
questionner sur ses besoins la voile à
nous poser la question de la limite de
la décence
moi je crois que l'expérience de vie des
campagnes aujourd'hui son suv 105 g sont
tous ceux dont on a parlé c'est la
dernière possibilité que l'on est de
véritablement se poser la question de
notre habité de la terre et de
l'écologie qui se joue derrière
voilà donc la ville du quart d'heure
excusez moi en plus c'est le fait
excuser mais j'ai des collègues qui
travaillent là dessus depuis une
trentaine d'années c'est assez
intéressant mais ça n'est que une forme
d'adaptation à la réalité d'aujourd'hui
ça ne pose pas la question du caractère
anti écologique de la massification
urbaine et de l' usage démesuré de
l'artificialisation voilà je vous
remercie tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]